on the mound for the halos making his
first start of the year matt and greece
here's jose altuve
breaking ball rolled toward third
rendell over to wren hifo quick turn and
got him
double play two down there's a quick
third turn transfer for champion rendon
ring heapo able to complete double play
nice turn now tube still runs well it's
all about that quick transfer friend
known as
gets that foot on the base and quickly
fires it first could be the double play
second inning no score lead off walk
stands at second guriel the base hit it
first
called strike three got on the inside
part of the plate outstanding spin race
this is loaded with one out for
left-handed hitting left fielder kyle
tucker
pass lestella into right field brantley
will score yuli will score
tucker to second base with a two rbi
double on the astros lead two to nothing
what what a swing of the bet by tucker i
mean a blink of an eye lestella the
first base but barely moves that's how
hard he hit it pieces are loaded two
made the eighth man the bat in the
inning and it's three nothing
pitch 12
and that's grounded left side to his
left the shortstop fletcher the second
for one room he full on the first that
is not in time as tucker scores to make
it four to nothing astros that's speed
got the astros another run
double play on probably 95 percent of
the players in the league bottom of the
third we go down four to nothing you
know we'll be in the next battery
based hit to right field fletcher is
going to be waved around
butterfield
brings him home rbi single for anthony
rendell and the angels get on the board
it's four to one houston that
is vintage anthony rindon the whole
field approach
clutches up with an rbi single
it's just so under control
his hands quiet and he was looking to
drive it that way kind of an inside out
approach with all that room on the right
side of the infield the bases are loaded
will be the next batter
maddie got him looking on a two-seam
fastball the angels will leave unloaded
a 5-2 ball game goodwin batting now
good one shoots went on towards center
field chasing springer back racing back
to the wall leads up did he get it no he
loses the glove it's a big fly for brian
goodwood
two-run shot
just to the left to center field the
angels are down by one good lateral
movement on the fastball he tried to run
that on the inside corner ran over the
plate and just over the wall
the angels with it around it's five to
four houston
but the one from middleton bregman ropes
it down the left field line and that
will stay fair and two hop the wall
bregman is on his way to second base and
he will cruise in with a double good way
to start off the fifth inning for alex
bregman and the astros yeah you're
hoping to get bregman going you get him
hot that changes the entire complexion
of this lineup here is yuli first and
third nobody out
euleg
sends wood this one deep enough to
center field bregman can trot home air
macedo won't even try and make the play
home he throws the ball back into second
and the astro tack on run number six of
the night on the sac fly by yuli guriel
that's a good professional at bat right
there by julie guriel getting at least
one run back so far good team baseball
right there after that first and second
here's carlos correa
[Music]
there's a walk
they're loaded up
big opportunity for tucker here who's
had a good game
and he grounds one through the hole in
the right side face and tucker in the
score brantley yulian to score two rbis
for kyle tucker and the astros with a
big two out hit and heated eighth of
four
that's a tough arm angle but he gets out
there
gets around it pulls it through the hole
on the right side and with two outs
everybody off with the swing he goes
trailing 8-5 here in the bottom of the
eight here's goodwin
that's pulled into the right field
corner that's going for extra bases
fletcher had a good jump he'll head to
third base he's probably going to be
sent home butterfield waving a home he's
going to
goody on his way to third he's got
himself an rbi triple it's eight to six
what a start to the season for goody
home run triple a couple of walks a
couple three rbis now for goodies gonna
be some damage done and it was by
goodwin you are with one out
one walk down to the right side
to correa over the first
inning ending double play just like that
in the bottom of the ninth inning
there's some magic left
and a four pitch walk
puts two on and he does
12th walk with the game for the healers
coming to the plate
[Music]
[Applause]
ground balls correa to his left and the
astros are winners tonight 9-6 the
astros win their first game on the road